Here is an extra fast, closed cast-on.
Now, it may not be the prettiest cast-on
you can find, but it is closed and it
will get your knitting started quickly.
It uses slip.
I'm showing it on a Brother
machine using the part buttons.
On Silver/Singer machines,
set the side levers to slip
and you'll get the same results.
Put into work the number of needles needed
and then pull every other
needle all the way out.
Let's call these the even number needles.
Set your carriage to slip.
On my Brother machine,
I engaged both part buttons.
Knit across.
Notice that the needles that you pulled
have loops and the needles that remained
in working position slipped.
The yarn passed under those needles.
Next, pull those slipped
needles all the way out.
Let's call these the odd needles,
with the carriage still
set to slip, knit across.
This time, the odd needles will have
a loop and the even needles form a loose,
somewhat sloppy stitch.
We'll do this again.
Pull the original, even needles
all the way out. Pass the carriage.
Again, the odd needles will slip.
Finally, pull the odd needles out.
When you knit, those odd needles will form
sloppy stitches and the even needles slip.
Continue knitting, and you'll see that you
have a nice closed cast-on that won't run,
but you did it in very few steps.
If you struggle with this, consider
using a cast-on comb on that first row.
It may help form
the stitches more cleanly.